c'est un dossier particulièrement
douloureux et vous avez pu remarquer
qu'à la dernière minute le témoin qui
n'est autre en fait que la soeur de
l'accusé principal qui dit avoir eu des
relations avec une maîtresse une
dénommée sandy au moment où les faits se
seraient déroulés les faits qu'on lui
reproche
ce témoin depuis trois ans et demi est
introuvable
il ne donne aucune indication et sa
soeur vient à la barre hier soir dire
mais moi je suis en relation avec elle
et éventuellement je pourrais l'a
retrouvé ce matin nous avons repris
l'audience est le témoin n'est toujours
pas présent mais si vous voulez cette
démarche a pour but sans nul doute de
jeter le trouble en fait on veut jeter
un trouble et on veut dire mais il ya
quelqu'un quand même qui pourrait
peut-être témoigner il ya quelque chose
de qui reste encore à définir
et donc les choses ne sont pas aussi
clair qu'on veut le prétendre pour vous
il n'ya pas de doute cet homme serait
effectivement le meurtrier de sept
enfants accusée par la main même si une
complicité puisque le dic a été un peu
surprise de ce monsieur est aussi ce
voisin qui a un peu participé à se
débarrasser du cours du côté de ma
pauvre il n'y a pas de doute pour moi il
n'ya pas de doute je suis parfaitement
convaincu de ce que j'avais plaidé
mais vous savez dans un dossier
d'assises il faut démêler beaucoup de
choses ce que nous sommes en train de
faire